figaro la vie figaro la ville et 16h03
et dans quelques instants vous pourrez
suivre en direct sur lefigaro.fr ainsi
que sur notre page youtube la page
youtube du figaro la conférence de
presse du procureur de la république de
toulouse
dominique alzeari qui va s'exprimer donc
dans quelques minutes sur l' enquête
autour de la disparition de delphine
jubile art jus billard son mari vient
d'être donc mis en examen pour meurtre
aggravé et je suis donc en studio avec
margot d'adhémar bonjour margot bonjour
vous êtes donc journaliste fait divers
au figaro vous avez suivi cette affaire
pour le figaro.fr
est-ce qu'on peut revenir très
rapidement avant que le procureur
s'exprime sur le dernier rebondissement
en date d'aujourd'hui
oui alors c'est évidemment la mise en
examen de cédric jus billard alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que son avocat
maître jean baptiste alary a déclaré que
c'était incohérent à ce stade du dossier
alors on se demande ce que va nous dire
le procureur de la république de
toulouse tout à l'heure il a été c'est
vrai que julliard a été déféré ce matin
devant les juges d'instruction est donc
logiquement on aurait pu se pose la
question est ce qu'il va être mis en
examen ou pas et c'est tombé tout à
l'heure il a été mis en examen
effectivement alors justement on peut
revenir du coup le rebondissement a eu
le plus y aura eu lieu plus tôt dans
cette semaine lors de la garde à vue
est-ce qu'on peut expliquer donc à tous
ceux qui n'ont peut-être pas suivi ces
derniers rebondissements de cette
semaine qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'elle était le calendrier cette
semaine comment se sont précipité les
choses
et bien c'est le mot un précipité vers
ce que pendant six mois six mois
d'enquêté ne se passait rien enfin en
tout cas tout était verrouillé on avait
accès à rien du tout et là d'un seul
coup en une semaine on a l'impression
que le dénouement de cette affaire est
en train de se faire on a vu mercredi
donc effectivement cédric du billard qui
a été placé en garde à vue
et puis ensuite ça s'est enchaîné donc
on a appris le procureur de la
république de toulouse dominique alzeari
nous a indiqué que la mère nadine
juillard de cette exubérance chute était
aussi placé en garde à vue
ensuite on a eu le beau père olivier
de cédric joubert aussi placé en garde à
vue ça a été vraiment l'enchaînement
l'enchaînement des rebondissements dans
cette affaire et ce kiosque est aussi
peut-être pas amusant mais en tout cas
étrange c'est que ces piles six mois
après sa disparition c'est à dire elle
est disparu le 16 décembre 2020 et
aujourd'hui enfin mercredi c'était le 16
juin 2021
son mari a été placé en garde à vue
est-ce que c'était l'unique suspect est
ce qu est ce qu il yad autres personnes
qui étaient suspectés dans cette affaire
alors alors il faut d'abord souligner un
fait c'est que au départ cédric
dubillard s'était constitué partie
civile c'est à dire qu'il était
considéré comme une victime
il avait été entendu le 30 avril dernier
il n'y avait pas de suspect en
particulier au départ même je me
souviens les enquêteurs pensaient à une
disparition volontaire en tout cas
c'était ce que pense et c'est de rugby
hier c'était c'était son son récit sa
version des faits et puis ensuite bon ça
c'est ça s'est enchaîné effectivement il
ya eu la découverte de ce confident de
montauban c'est comme ça que les
enquêteurs l'appel qui auraient échangé
des messages avec des fines julliard et
on l'a vu dans l'article du parisien il
aurait prévu de déménager prochainement
lesquels de refaire sa vie avec elle
alors lui tout de suite il a été mis
hors de cause c'est à dire il n'avait
pas du tout et pour quel motif
la lente est suspecté il apparaîtrait
selon le parisien qu' il se trouvait à
ce moment là au moment des faits avec
son ex compagne qui a pu en tout cas
doté un alibi tout à fait donner un
alibi témoigne enfin safa leurs autres
sens où elle a confirmé qu'elle se
trouvait avec lui à ce moment là si vous
nous rejoignez dans quelques instants
donc sur figaro live sur la page youtube
du figaro est également sur le figaro.fr
le procureur de la république de
toulouse dominique alzeari doit donner
une conférence de presse sur tous ces
rebondissements dans l' enquête sur la
disparition de delphine jus billard nous
l'attendons dans quelques instants il
devait s'exprimer à 16 heures il est 16h
il ne devrait pas tarder en tout cas je
vous lis dans le chat de la page youtube
du figaro vous êtes très très nombreux
je vais vous saluer bonjour anthony
carrier bonjour philippe m bonjour marie
maffre bon jour s'est levé bonjour
rachid idrissi
si vous avez la moindre question sur l'
enquête sur le profil de cédric jus
billard margot qui est avec moi en
studio sera un plaisir de de vous
répondre si elle connaît la réponse bien
sûr alors n'hésitez pas à poser toutes
vos questions je vous lis je vous
regarde je vous suis et je relève aux
questions moi j'ai une petite question
concernant donc ces six mois des
enquêtes
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure que
c'était totalement anormal qu'on ait si
peu d'informations pourquoi rien n'a
fuité pendant ces six mois
alors je dis anormales parce que c'est
vrai que quand bon quand on travaille
sur des sur des faits divers des sujets
comme celui ci des affaires sûr on peut
toujours arriver à avoir des
informations
et justement hier je discute avec une
avocate qui me dit mais vous rendez pas
compte c'est ça la norme c'est à dire la
norme ça devrait être la faire du bien
c'est à dire tous devraient être tout le
temps verrouillé dans tous dans tout ce
jour deux ans tout ce type d'affaires là
alors pourquoi ça ne suffisait pas on ne
sais pas peut-être parce qu'il y avait
des choses graves
peut-être on ne sait pas justement tout
est complètement fermée alors je vous
regarde je vous lis donc sur le chat du
figaro.fr bonjour à interel bonjour à
faute à voltaire et bonjour à yoann
d'eads a ainsi qu'à vole pas eu 34 merci
d'être avec nous pour ce direct dans
quelques instants
dominique alzeari je vous rappelle doit
prendre la parole et tenir une
conférence de presse
il s'agit donc du procureur de la
république de toulouse yohann de da nous
déclare la gendarmerie a pris son temps
mais il vaut mieux avoir un dossier bien
bouclée face à la justice
est ce que l'on sait d'ores et déjà ce
qui a confondu ou en tout cas quels sont
les indices concordants qui ont mené à
cette mise en examen de cédric du
billard alors effectivement pour qu'il y
ait une mise en examen il faut qu'ils
aient des indices graves ou concordants
concordants pardon
alors on sait par le parisien qu' il y
aurait apparemment des captures d'écran
qu'on aurait retrouvé dans le téléphone
de ses origines billard où il y aurait
sa femme en tenue de nuit et cette photo
là elle l'aurait envoyé à ce fameux
confident de montauban quelques minutes
avant sa disparition donc il ya ce
premier point là qui pourrait être
intéressant et le second c'est aussi
d'autres captures d'écran qui ont été
retrouvés dans le téléphone de cédric du
billard où l'on voit le profil du fameux
confident on peut se demander pourquoi
est ce qu'il a un profil facebook un
devis pourquoi il ay là
pris en photo voilà ce se profile pour
l'instant à ce qu'on sait après
peut-être que les enquêteurs ont relevé
des incohérences dans le récit de cédric
julliard et ont voulu le confronter à
justement tous et tout cet aspect là du
récit qui peut-être ne concordent pas
avec d'autres éléments que eux ont pu
retrouver durant ces six mois des
enquêtes est ce qu on sait justement si
le procureur doit annoncer des détails
sur sur cette enquête est ce qu'il
pourrait livrer jusqu'où du coup à la
presse d'autres indices graves que la
presse n'a pas révélé que le parisien
n'a pas rêvé avec bien sûr bien sûr je
pense que là c'est si tout sort comme ça
d'un coup c'est forcément que les
enquêteurs sont sur le point de
découvrir ce qui est arrivé à delphine
juillard en tout cas on espère notamment
pour la famille pour qui c'est très
difficile dans le cas des disparitions
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé avec la
personne
c'est très éprouvant est ce qu est ce qu
elle est décédée ce qu'elle est vivante
voilà qui est impliquée je pense que
j'espère en tout cas que le procureur de
la république va pouvoir aborder ces
questions là alors dans le chat vous
êtes très nombreux sur sur youtube merci
merci à vous de nous suivre
il y à moi moi moi jolie login qui nous
demandent si cédric jubilaire a avoué
alors ça on ne sait pas pour l'instant
on sait qu'il a été mis en examen après
effectivement quelle va être sa défense
est-ce qu'il va continuer à affirmer
tout ce qu'il a dit depuis six mois
importe puisque pendant six mois il a
clamé envers et contre tous qu'il était
innocent on l'a vu aussi ce matin sur
france 3 en occitanie sa nouvelle
compagne qui assure qu'il est innocent
elle aussi elle dit j'espère que je me
suis pas trompé en tout cas voilà elle
le croit elle le croit innocent est-ce
que cédric juillard va garder
ce récit là cette version là où est-ce
qu'il va au contraire
en tout cas si si c'est le cas bien sûr
lorsqu'il est toujours présumé innocent
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas on le
verra j'espère tout à l'heure quel est
justement la version qu'il a livrés aux
gendarmes depuis le début est ce qu'on
peut revenir sur sur l'effet initiaux
vous sur cette alerte
de disparition sur 7 ouais sur ce
signalement de disparition qu'il avait
donnée c'est lui même qui a alerté les
gendarmes c'est ça c'est ça tout à fait
alors ce que dit cédric gobilliard c'est
que il sa femme est partie à 23h
promener les chiens avec une doudoune
blanche et son téléphone est en plein
couvre-feu d'ailleurs à 23h et que les
chiens seraient rentrés sans elle lui
aurait été réveillé vers 4 heures du
matin par les pleurs de leur petite
fille
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre 23
heures et 4 heures du matin on ne s'est
pas en tout cas il a tout de suite
appelé ont envoyé des sms aux amis de
delphine du billard où il disait est ce
que des fines et chez toi dit à delphine
de rentrer donc il y avait en tout cas
on pourrait penser qu'en face à ccm est
cela qui pensaient que définie julliard
se trouvait chez ses amis et puis
ensuite il a prévenu effectivement les
autorités en leur disant je pense que ça
pensé que c'était une disparition
volontaire et ça les proches de delphine
gilbert n'ont jamais cru à la
disparition volontaire ceux qui se sont
exprimés dans la presse en tout cas
alors jamais cru je pense que les
proches de la famille de delphine
les proches d'un film billard pense
surtout aux enfants
en tout cas c'est ce que dit m nakache à
harry qui est le l'avocat des proches de
delphine du billard il dit les enfants
c'est tout ce qui compte
vous imaginez ce qu'ils sont en train de
vivre ils n'ont plus leur mère est là on
est en train de mettre en cause leur
père fin c'est un cetain c'est un enfer
donc la famille privilégie avant tout
les enfants pour l'instant je n'ai pas
l'impression qu'ils voilà qu'ils aient
envie de dire ce qu'il pense vraiment ça
se comprend aussi beaucoup de questions
justement dans le chat qui rebondissent
à ce que vous dites sur les enfants
marie maffre et qui nous demande qui
garde les enfants
est-ce qu'ils vont être placés est-ce
que c'est déjà ça a déjà été annoncé non
pas du tout ça pas été annoncés après
est-ce qu'ils vont être placés bas si
effectivement il s'avère que bon c'est
vrai jus billard et
est en cause dans cette affaire peut on
ne sait pas ce qui va arriver des
enfants est ce qu'ils ont de la famille
jeu pour l'instant je crois savoir
qu'ils sont chez des proches
est-ce qu'ils vont y rester ou pas on ne
sait pas mais c'est vrai qu'on le voit
dans d'autres affaires similaires je
pense par exemple à magali blandin
les enfants ont été placés je me
souviens bien parce qu'effectivement
leur mère était décédée
c'est leur père est suspecté est
suspecté après il s'est avéré que
c'était lui qui avait tué sa femme qui
avait prévu en fait de tuer sa femme qui
avait demandé à des géorgiens
d'organiser le meurtre et finalement ils
s'étaient rétractés et il l'avait fait
lui même avec une batte de baseball
quand elle rentrait dans son appartement
et ça a été découvert et effectivement
les enfants se sont retrouvés sans aucun
parent oui voilà arrive donc dans ce cas
c'est la lada ce qui les place ou deux
où c'est la justice qui les place ça
dépend s'ils ont de la famille qui
peuvent s'en occuper ou pas et là est ce
qu'on sait s'il ya de la famille est ce
qu'on peut faire un petit profil
justement de cette famille quel âge on
les enfants de cédric et delphine du
billard alors de mémoire ils ont raison
je ne me souviens plus alors je crois
que c'était sept ans et deux ans donc
ils sont assez jeunes sont des mineurs
ça faisait 15 ans que delphine et c'est
vrai qu'ils étaient mariés ils sont
mariés en 2013
alors il avait un clip de couple un peu
particulier parce que c'était julliard
avait des soucis lille et il a été de
formation c'est un peintre en bâtiment
il avait monté son entreprise mais il
l'avait rencontré certaines difficultés
donc on peut dire c'était un peu
delphine julliard qui faisait bouillir
la marmite avec son métier donc
d'infirmières albi est ce que disent en
tout cas les voisins ce qu'on a pu lire
dans la presse aussi c'était quelqu'un
qui s'occupait énormément de ses enfants
c'était une mère de famille avant tout
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les proches
qui avait témoigné dans la presse je ne
sais plus dans quel type disait que
c'était ce n'était pas possible qu'elle
abandonne volontairement ses enfants
voilà exactement c'est ce que dit aussi
m nakache harris et que effectivement
pour les proches de la famille d alfie
lumière il est impensable qu'elle ait pu
abandonner comme ça ses enfants donc
tout ce qui est disparition volontaire
pour eux on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est peu probable
après voilà reste à le prouver bien sûr
mais ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
brûle est envisageable
voilà vous avez enquêté d'ailleurs il ya
un papier qui est signé de votre plume
dans le figaro sur les disparitions
inquiétantes 1 dont faisait partie celle
de delphine jupiler à partir de quand et
sur quels critères justement les
gendarmes ou les autorités décident de
de déclarer que telle disparition est
inquiétante
oui alors ça c'est très intéressant
effectivement alors quand c'est un
mineur s'est automatiquement une
disparition inquiétante il ya
automatiquement une enquête quand c'est
une personne majeure ont fait au cas par
cas
c'est à dire par exemple bon si il y à
des indices qui montrent que bon la fa
la la la la personne ne devrait pas être
disparu par exemple je me souvient d'un
gendarme qu'il me disait si par exemple
elle ne répond pas à ses enfants
c'est un critère pour dire disparition
inquiétante
donc là dans notre affaire julien
effectivement elle ne répond pas à ses
enfants
donc voilà après c'est vrai que c'est
très difficile d'enquêter sur des
disparitions inquiétantes
on le voit avec cette affaire julien qui
dure 2 avec l'en quête qui dure depuis
six mois
c'est compliqué parce qu'il n'y a pas de
scène de crime d'ailleurs les gendarmes
parlent de seine d'enlèvement il n'y a
pas de corps en général très peu de
celle et très peu d'un 10
alors il faut aussi travailler très vite
parce que tout c'est une course c'est
une véritable course contre la montre
ils doivent rassembler les premiers
éléments rapidement parce que pour eux
plus le temps passe moins il ya de
chances de retrouver la personne
disparue et la cie - par exemple six
mois d' enquête avant de danser un
déféré le un suspect dans cette enquête
est ce que c'est c'est un temps normal
pour une enquête de ce type sur une
disparition inquiétante ou est-ce que
ces longs ou est-ce que c'est trop court
est ce que c'est à peu près combien de
temps met ces disparitions être résolus
alors c'est une grande question est
effectivement je pense que c'est au cas
par cas parce que on le voit d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui il ya plein de disparition
qui se transforme en calcaire cette
affaire qui ne sont jamais résolus
on pense par exemple à estelle mouzin ça
fait 20 ans estelle mouzin qu'elle ait
disparu on trouve rien on va sur telles
pistes telles pistes mais on n'arrive
pas à déterminer qui pourrait vraiment
être à l'origine de sa disparition alors
envoyé six mois 20 ans ça peut varier
vraiment c'est au cas par cas
ça dépend des indices que trouvent les
enquêteurs ça dépend aussi de la
situation de après c'est vrai qu'il ya
des types de disparition différentes
dans le sens où et c'est amusant c'est
une disparition d'enfant
là c'est une jeune femme adulte et est
âgé de 33 ans elle est active
professionnellement elle est là des
enfants ella ella un entourage
et c'est vrai que c'est ça aussi qui
rend la chose inquiétante c'est que rien
ne laissait penser qu'un jour delphine
julliard disparaîtrait si vous nous
rejoignez nous sommes toujours en direct
sur lefigaro.fr mais également sur la
page youtube du figaro la page figaro
live marie maffre et maffre qui est dans
le chat depuis le début sur youtube nous
demande quand est ce que le procureur va
parler bien nous aussi on l'attend il
devait
il devait parler à 16 heures il est 16
heures 20 en tout cas nous restons en
direct avec vous pour l'attendre et je
vous assure que dès que le procureur de
la république de toulouse démarrera sa
conf de presse
on vous la mettra en la diffusant en
direct
gym question c'est pas vraiment une
question mais une remarque de quelqu'un
dans notre chatte monsieur pure qui me
qui parle des parents de cédric jus
billard et qui disent que forcément ses
parents devraient être au courant si
jamais il avait tué sa femme
est-ce qu'on peut alors on peut pas
répondre à cette question évidemment
parfois dans la fête des parents de
monsieur jubilaire mais est-ce qu'on
peut revenir sur sur sa maman qui a été
en garde est en garde à vue en même
temps que son fils est ce qu'on sait si
elle est entendue comme témoin ou est-ce
qu'elles risquent des poursuites
est-ce qu'on a une suite de cette garde
à vue alors effectivement les parents
enfin le lamer nadine julliard et le
beau père de cédric julliard olivier ont
été placés en garde à vue en même temps
pratiquement que c'était du bien c'était
mercredi dernier
mercredi 16 juin on peut penser que si
les enquêteurs ont jugé pertinent de les
placer en garde à vue c'est qu'il y a
quelque chose forcément
est ce que peut-être c'est du billard
aurait pu mettre au courant ses parents
est ce qu il les aurait appelés alors si
on pense évidemment à magali blandin on
peut se dire ce qu il ya un complot
comme ce fut le cas pour cette affaire
blandin c'est sûr que les enquêteurs ont
dû se poser des questions d'autant plus
que si ma mémoire est bonne c'est vrai
que j'ai eus billard à son téléphone qui
s'est allumé durant la nuit donc entre
ce laps de temps dont on parlait tout à
l'heure 23 heures 4 heures du matin est
ce qu'il a essayé de joindre quelqu'un à
ce moment là on ne sait pas mais c'est
possible peut-être que ce sont les
parents puisqu'ils ont été placés en
garde à vue après la bière d'avion a été
levée ça aurait été enfin les enquêteurs
le le savez sûrement dès le départ s'il
avait joint ses parents entre 23h à 4h
ça m'est pas six mois a relevé des
fadettes quand même et c'est je vous
rejoins tout à fait effectivement c'est
une question que je me pose aussi je me
dis mais comment c'est possible ou que
ce soit pas sorti plus tôt parce que en
six mois c'est la première chose je veux
tu en voilà quand j'ai écrit ce papier
sur les disparitions inquiétantes ce que
les enquêteurs me disais c'est la
première chose qu'on fait c'est tout ce
qui est élément de téléphonie bornage
enquête de voisinage ont toutes ces
choses là elles ont été faites tout de
suite et c'est vrai que moi si je ne
comprends pas pourquoi est-ce que ça
ressort que maintenant alors que ça
aurait vu
arrivée en surface beaucoup plus tôt si
vous êtes avec nous donc merci de nous
suivre nous attendons toujours le
procureur de la république de toulouse
dominique alzeari qui doit s'exprimer
dans quelques instants il a plus d'une
vingtaine de minutes de retard comme
nous l'attendons tous cas nous
diffuserons en direct je vous rappelle
que il doit s'exprimer sur l'anc est de
la disparition de delphine jubilaire
puisque son mari cédric jus billard
vient d'être mise en examen pour meurtre
aggravé et je suis donc avec margot
d'adhémar journaliste fait divers au
figaro qui suit cette affaire pour le
figaro est-ce qu'on peut expliquer à aux
internautes qui nous regarde ce que
c'est qu'une mise en examen pour meurtre
aggravé
pour meurtres aggravés ça signifie que
alors mise en examen déjà c'est parce
que c'est une décision du juge
d'instruction dans le cadre d'une
information judiciaire
ça signifie qu'une personne est
soupçonnée d'infraction et contre
laquelle il existe des indices graves et
concordants qui voilà qui justifie cette
mise en examen
ce qui signifie aussi que les libertés
donc de ses ex du billard peuvent être
limités par exemple on peut penser à une
mesure de contrôle judiciaire ou même à
une mesure de détention provisoire donc
c'est vrai que ce comment dire c'est un
pas de plus vers
quelque chose est en tout cas il ya
quelque chose qui montrent quelque chose
de pas net
voyez c'est ça qui est qu on aimerait
savoir aujourd'hui à la conférence de
presse du procureur c'est finalement
pourquoi d'un seul coup cette garde à
vue mercredi et deux jours plus tard
mise en examen c'est sait quand même
qu'il doit y avoir quelque chose
d'important à dire en tout cas j'espère
que monsieur le procureur nous dira tout
à l'heure et tout en ne sachant pas s'il
a avoué parce que s'il a avoué la mise
en examen découle plus facilement on ne
sait pas s'il a avoué mais c'est vrai
que s'il avoue avoir tué sa femme ou en
tout cas être impliqué dans la
disparition de détenus billard c'est
voilà c'est je pense que personne ne s'y
attend pas ce que durant six mois il a
quand même martelé qu'il était innocent
sur les réseaux sociaux
je me souviens qu'il avait publié un
post disant allez voir ailleurs si ceux
qui pensent que je ne suis je n'arrive
plus à citer exactement mais il avait en
tout cas prouver enfin prouver il
assumer pleinement son innocence de a à
z
il n'a jamais flanché alors qu'on voit
juste juste en ce moment ces images donc
ce ne sont pas des images en direct mais
ce sont des images des patrouilles en
tout cas des battues pour retrouver
delphine jus billard est ce qu on sait
combien ont été organisées depuis depuis
sa disparition
ces images que l'on voit en ce moment
qui sont diffusées donc c'est l'une des
battues qui a été organisée par les
gendarmes
pour retrouver delphine jus biya il me
semble qu'il y en a eu une récemment
encore oui c'est ça alors moi je me
souviens surtout de labatut citoyenne
qui avait été organisée fin décembre et
qui avait quand même réuni un millier de
personnes
puis de nouveau là tout récemment samedi
samedi 12 juin à albi il y avait une
marche blanche qui réunit les proches et
les collègues de delphine subi hier
d'ailleurs on l'a vu cédric g billard
était présent avec son fils il était là
et il y avait 6 s'est exprimé devant la
presse déjà
non il est il est très réticent face à
l'idée de s'exprimer dans la presse
alors il l'a déjà fait mais ce sont
toujours des petites bribes file il
c'est pas quelqu'un qui m'aime boyer par
ses voisins il est toujours décrit comme
quelqu'un d'assez solitaire d' assez
renfermé
contrairement à delphine qui elle est
décrite comme quelqu'un d'assez
rayonnant voilà qui va vers les autres
donc c'est vraiment de profil assez
complémentaires et il n'avait pas il
s'était pas spécifiquement exprimer
/ voilà ce qu'est ce qu'ils pensaient de
la disparition de sa femme
après c'est vrai que c'est assez
frappant de se dire le samedi 12 juin
cédric g billard manif a même testé
cette marche blanche en l'honneur de sa
femme et quatre jours plus tard non
c'est ça il avait mercredi caterpillar
mercredi 16 juin interpellé alors lucas
vie yeux mier dans le tchat sur notre
page youtube nous pose une question
cette garde à vue simultanée en fait
donc de cédric joubert de sa mère et de
son beau-père
at-elle été justement faite
simultanément pour les empêcher qu'ils
communiquent entre eux peut-on penser
que les parents pourraient avoir envie
de s'accorder sur une version et
protéger ainsi leur fils oui tout à fait
je pense que c'est pour ça aussi que les
enquêteurs se sont tus pendant si
longtemps c'était aussi parce qu'ils
avaient cette volonté peut-être de faire
croire à cédric du billard qui n'était
pas observé et puis finalement au moment
où il commençait un peu peut-être à se
dire que bon c'était terminé
il avait publié d'ailleurs il ya
quelques semaines une photo de lui avec
sa compagne sur facebook qui avait fait
beaucoup parler
on peut penser effectivement que ils ont
souhaité que toutes ces gardes à vue là
soient organisées en même temps pour
qu'ils n'aient pas le temps de
communiquer pour qui les pales qu'il
n'ait pas le temps de n'ai pas le temps
de s'accorder sur une version des faits
ou peut-être d'aller effacer des traces
ou récupérer des éléments qui pourraient
être peut-être compromettants alors je
continue de vous lire sur le chat de
youtube vous être très nombreux
notamment
mayline qui nous dit apparemment et
cédric jeux billard aurait dit à
quelqu'un par sms je les grilles est
juste avant sa disparition concernant
donc l'infidélité de son ex femme est-ce
que vous avez des informations
là-dessus margot oui alors on l'a vu
dans le papier du parisien effectivement
cédric du billard aurait envoyé ou en
tout cas dit à une personne de son
entourage
gg delphine jeu j'ai grillé delphine
c'est pas au moment de sa disparition
c'est juste après je crois que c'est le
lendemain de mémoire donc c'est vrai
qu'on peut se poser des questions sa
femme disparaît et le lendemain il a il
assure à
une personne de son entourage qui l'a
grillé grille et bien évidemment dans le
sens qu'il a découvert quelque chose à
son sujet on pourrait se poser la
question pourquoi ça ça fait partie si
vous voulez de ces éléments là qui sème
le doute
comme cette histoire de capture d'écran
du confident de montauban comme cette
histoire de photos que delphine envoie à
son confident juste avant d'aller se
coucher en disant qu'elle va se coucher
elle est en tenue de nuit parce
qu'évidemment on se dit si elle envoie à
22h58 une photo d'elle en pyjama ou
autre à son à son amant elle ne va pas
sortir les chiens à 23h voiliers
français s'est dit d'ailleurs on met un
peu oui la puce à l'oreille peut-être
qui a mis la puce à l'oreille des
enquêteurs
mais pourquoi six mois après fois c'est
vraiment la question qu'on se pose
aujourd'hui parce que ces émeutes ces
éléments là il avait depuis longtemps en
fait le fait qu'elle ait envoyé cette
photo à son amant ils n'ont pas appris
il ya une semaine
c'est une question qu'on se pose
effectivement est-ce-qu'il parce que
effectivement s'il l'avait su avant je
pense que tout serait ce serait
peut-être enchaîné un peu plus
rapidement
ou est-ce que c'était volontaire est ce
qu'il le savait dès le départ mais il
n'avait peut-être pas assez d'éléments
pour incriminer de telle ou telle
personne et donc ils ont préféré
attendre le temps d'avoir un dossier
peut être un peu plus solide
si vous nous rejoignez donc nous sommes
en direct sur lefigaro.fr et aussi sur
la page youtube du figaro car nous
attendons donc la conférence de presse
du procureur de la république de
toulouse
dominique alzeari qui doit faire le
point sur l'enquêté notamment sur la
grosse avancée dans l'enquêté sur la
disparition de delphine juillard vous
savez c'est cette infirmière de 33 ans
qui avait disparu mi-décembre dans le
tarn
en effet aujourd'hui donc tout à l'heure
à la mi-journée donc son mari mari a été
mise en examen pour meurtre aggravé à
l'issue d'une garde à vue qui a duré
plus de 48 heures c'est ça oui c'est ça
un peu plus de 48 heures il a été placé
en garde à
vue mercredi après midi à albi sur son
lieu de travail et ensuite la garde à
vue a été prolongée
donc elle a duré jusqu'à cet après midi
il a il a déféré devant le juge
en fin de matinée et donc là on a appris
en début et en milieu d'après midi qu'il
était mis en examen et on attend d'en
savoir plus grâce à la conférence de
presse du procureur de la république de
toulouse
est ce qu'on sait si il est écroué déjà
ou pas du tout il est simplement mis en
examen on ne sait pas s'il va dormir ce
soir en prison
non c'est pas effectivement est ce que
est ce qu'il va y avoir une détention
provisoire ou plutôt à un contrôle
judiciaire on sait pas encore exactement
quelles vont être les suites
en tout cas il peut contester sa mise en
examen
on verra sa réaction je pense dans les
prochains jours et c'est ça qui est
assez assez fou aussi dans cette affaire
c'est que il ya une accélération
incroyable des événements vous savez il
ya eu cette disparition le le 16 16
décembre 2020
et puis ensuite rien à part quelques
quelques petits éléments qui ressortait
mais qui aujourd'hui nous semble
insignifiant par rapport à ce qui est en
train de se passer
on se souvient que le compte de delphine
julliard avait été réactivé le compte
facebook
je crois deux fois et
certains internautes l'avez remarqué il
avait même envoyé un sms à delphine en
dix ans delphine es tu là parce qu'ils
avaient vu vous savez la petite pastille
verte sur messenger bah voilà est ce
qu'on sait ce que c'est aujourd'hui ce
bug alors ce que ce que ce que ce qu'on
dit des les enquêteurs est ce que nous
ont dit les avocats c'est que s'avérait
que c'est un bug c'est à dire un bug
informatique voilà c'était un hasard
finalement mais quand même un téléphone
qui sert active un conte fins et c'est
vrai que c'est perturbant dans ce genre
d'affaires la après tout est possible
il se peut tout à fait que ce soit
simplement un bug est peut-être qu'il ya
eu des manipulations qui ont fait que
peut-être que c'est vraiment delphine on
ne sait pas du tout mais ce sont les
seuls éléments d'enquêté enfin weeds
enquêtes qui sont ressortis durant ces
six mois
et là vous voyez on arrive à la mise en
examen garde à vue il en examen d'un
seul coup c'est vraiment on est tenu de
l'explosion en haleine au moins
surprenant donc justement cédric
julliard donc le mari de delphine julien
vient d'être mise en examen pour pour
meurtre aggravé pour l'instant il est
toujours évidemment présumé innocent est
ce qu'on sait margot s'il ya déjà eu
d'autres suspects durant ces six mois
des enquêtes ou s'il n'y a pas eu
d'autres de garde autres gardes à vue
non il n'y a pas eu il n'y a pas eu
d'autres gardes à vue effectivement
à un moment les enquêteurs se sont
orientés vers ce confident de montauban
parce que c'est vrai qu'on se demandait
qui était-il quelles étaient ses
relations avec d'être finie dubillard
comment s'étaient rencontrés et
finalement et c'est très vite avéré
qu'il a été très vite mis hors de cause
d'ailleurs on a pu lire à un entretien
dans le parisien où il explique que
delphine lui manque terriblement que
c'est avec lui qu'elle a eu ces derniers
échanges par sms est ce que est ce que
c'est finalement la dernière fois que
delphine du billard a eu un contact avec
quelqu'un est ce qu'il ya des toujours
en vie à ce qu'a dit on ne sait pas mais
en tout cas cette personne n'a le fameux
confident de montauban a été rapidement
mis hors de cause et cette liaison donc
elle entretenait au moins une liaison
téléphonique c'est ça est-ce qu'ils
s'étaient déjà rencontrés physiquement
on le sait alors personnellement je n'ai
pas d'information à ce sujet en revanche
ce que dit le parisien c'est que il
avait noué une relation profonde qui
allait au-delà d'une relation
épistolaire et qui le prévient qu'il
louis et qu'il souhaitait aménager
ensemble qu'il souhaitait changer de vie
voilà et c'est vrai que ça peut aussi
enfin c'est ce qu'ils ont dit les
enquêteurs ça peut aussi poser question
dans le sens où on se demande si
finalement delphine du billard n'aurait
pas annoncé à son mari qu'elle
souhaitait le quitter définitivement
qu'elle avait rencontré quelqu'un
qu'elle aurait peut-être révéler son
identité on ne sait pas et que c'est là
que julliard serait entré dans un accès
de colère et qu'il y aurait eu une
violente dispute
et quelle a été la suite de ces disputes
on ne sait pas mais forcément ça nous
fait penser je le vois sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux
ça nous fait penser à la sphère d'aval
ou de manière similaire on a vu qu'il y
avait cette dispute qui avait conduit au
drame
alors il ne faut pas faire d'amalgamé
dit m alary l'avocat de ces ong billard
et effectivement il est toujours présumé
innocent mais c'est vrai qu'il ya se
voit là on parle toujours des tribunaux
populaires là effectivement nombreux
sont ceux à faire le parallèle avec la
sphère d'aval alors qu'il convient quand
même de ne pas faire d'amalgamé marie
amélie dans le chatt rebondi dessous du
cou sur ce que vous dit et vous
interpelle margot est ce qu on a une
idée du moment où ça a commencé à mal se
passer dans le couple alors il
semblerait que ce soit lié au fait que
cédric julliard avait des difficultés
professionnelles
donc il y avait un déséquilibre dans le
couple on l'a dit tout à l'heure
effectivement delphine subi hier c'est
elle qui faisait bouyer bouillir la
marmite c'est elle qui qui qui non
seulement s'occuper énormément des
enfants mais aussi enchaîner les nuits
de garde regarde voilà elle était
infirmière à albi et c'est peut-être là
qu'il y a eu que quelque chose s'est
nouée et finalement qui a qui a mené à
la disparition de delphine julliard est
ce que est ce que ses proches savait
qu'elle voulait le quitter
ça c'est une grande question je ne sais
pas honnêtement je ne sais pas après
j'imagine que bon parfois dans ces
situations là effectivement certaines
personnes préfèrent être discrète quand
d'autres en parlent
est-ce que delphine julien fait partie
des personnes discrètes ou des personnes
qui ont besoin d'en parler on ne sait
pas mais tout est possible dans quelques
instants si vous nous rejoignez merci
d'être en direct avec nous donc sur
lefigaro.fr mme sy sur notre page
youtube figaro live
vous voyez donc les images en direct de
toulouse le procureur de la république
dominique alzéari doit s'exprimer dans
quelques instants il a donc oui un peu
plus d'une demi heure de retard
désormais vous voyez donc les micros qui
sont déjà prêts j'imagine que tout est
prêt pour que le procureur s'exprime une
déclaration donc très attendue puisque
en fait c'est l'une des seule prise de
parole officielle on va dire en tout cas
en tant que concept de presse qu'on a vu
depuis le début de cette enquête
finalement oui c'est ça depuis le début
de l' enquête l'a enfin tout est
complètement verrouillé on a accès
absolument rien en tout cas n'a fuité
même les les on a vu les avocats aussi
n'était pas très il était assez avare de
paroles c'était c'était compliqué pour
eux de parler on voit m alary qui
commence à s'exprimer notamment sur
cette mise en examen
il dit que à ce stade du dossier quand
même sans corps sans connaître les
origines d'un décès dont on ignore
jusqu'à la réalité retenir une intention
homicide est ahurissant donc c'est vrai
voilà on voit tout de suite on commence
peut-être un peu deviner quelle va être
la défense de 7 juillet c'est une vanne
y est si on l'incriminent si on l'accuse
en tout cas d'être impliquée dans la
disparition de son épouse delphine julia
je vous coupe margot regarder il vient
d'arriver on va l'écouter tous ensemble
en direct sur figaro life dominique
alzeari
bien mesdames et messieurs je me
présente à vous donc que procure la
république parquet de toulouse et je
suis accompagné du colonel philippe coup
et commandant la section de recherches
de toulouse où comprenant d'occitanie
ainsi que monsieur le colonel 2d qui est
le commandant de groupement de la
gendarmerie du tarn qui a été activement
bien sûr elle impliquée dans cette
affaire
dès son début je voulais avant de vous
exposer les éléments qui n'est permis de
vous communiquer sur cette affaire qui
connaît un retentissement et d'autre
part qui a connu des développements
récents importants droit payet que
j'interviens devant vous au titre
l'article 11 alinéa 3 du code de
procédure pénale qui autorise le
procureur et en l'occurrence entre
l'accord des magistrats instructeurs
concernés à communiquer publiquement sur
des éléments d'un dossier sont portés de
leur appréciation sur les charges mais
en rappelant des éléments objectifs
puisqu'il s'agit ici de prévenir tout
risque de divulgation d'informations
parcellaires ou inexactes ou encore
comme le prévoit le texte de faire
cesser le trouble à l'ordre public ce
qui n'est pas en direct ici mais quand
on voit les l'émotion qu'a causé cette
affaire juste titre puisque aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la configuration
domicile conjugal semble-t-il il je
crois que il est important aussi de
rappeler deux choses en amont la
communication sur ce dossier a été
volontairement retardé un accord et la
demande des magistrats instructeurs
même si la couverture médiatique était
importante pour assurer l'intégrité et
la sérénité des investigations qui ont
été développées de manière parfaitement
exceptionnelle par les gendarmes
agissant sous l'autorité du juge
d'instruction
après avoir travaillé le parquet d'albi
et qui ont conduit effectivement à ces
développements les plus récents
en ce qui concerne donc ce dossier qui
part bien sûr d'une disparition d'une
personne est donc aujourd'hui trouve une
qualification juridique
je vous citerai simplement pour vous
donner une idée des investigations qui
ont été développées et les deux colonels
qui m'accompagne pourront compléter en
tant que de besoin à tout moment entre
tout à l'heure en tout cas depuis
l'ouverture cette information le 23
décembre dernier par le pôle criminel du
parquet de toulouse suite à
dessaisissement du parquet d'albi qui
pendant les huit premiers jours regarder
le dossier en disparition inquiétante
l'ouverture d'information dont qui a été
fait 23 juillet immédiatement par le
parquet de toulouse sans continuer
l'enquète a donné lieu à plus de 2500
actes et procès verbaux en six mois
quasiment jour pour jour à plus d'une
quarantaine d' expertise officiellement
diligentée elle à nous mobiliser des
moyens matériels considérables dont vous
nous avez rendu compte au fur et à
mesure des opérations
je pense notamment aux opérations de
ratissage qui ont été faites sur plus de
10 kilomètres autour du domicile avec
des moyens pouvant aller jusqu'à plus
d'une centaine de gendarmes ont colonel
et avec la constitution d'une cellule
enquête de dix personnes plein temps au
tour du colonel coup et qui ont
travaillé
sans désemparer depuis cette date sans
parler bien sûr des opérations de
recherche citoyenne c'était en plus
encadré systématiquement par la
gendarmerie comme vous le savez il
fallait donc ne pas précipiter ne pas
non plus interférer alors que chaque
élément
chaque information nouvelle devait être
exploitées avec le plus de sérénité et
d'objectivité possible et permettre
ainsi si ça ne plus être le cas et c'est
au centre bien sûr du dossier de
rechercher la personne disparue et si
possible de la trouver
ce qui n'a pas encore été le cas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui mais cette communication est
aujourd'hui tout à fait légitime puisque
il faut d'abord bien évidemment rendre
compte des derniers développements de
cette affaire qui s'est donc accéléré
cette section mène sans égard pour les
demandes qui ont pu être faites
d'intervention puisque je vous explique
pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait et parce
qu'il ya un secret de l'instruction et
que j'ai la prétention de le respecter
scrupuleusement
et puis d'autre part parce que il faut
aussi répondre même si le juge
d'instruction le fonds directement aux
interrogations des victimes il y à 13
parties civiles dans ce dossier
actuellement et d'autre part peut-être
répondre aux interrogations de nos
concitoyens qui par votre truchement ont
été sensibilisés comme et c'est tout à
fait naturel à cette affaire aussi
complexe que grave qui justifie la
mobilisation très importante comme c'est
le cas partout en france chaque fois
qu'il ya ce type de dossier qui a été le
les six mêmes de l'action de la
gendarmerie les investigations ont
conduit vous le savez à la mise en garde
à vue le monsieur cédric jibidar 16 juin
soit six mois jour pour jour après la
disparition son épouse ainsi qu'avec son
sa mère et son beau-père ceux ci ont été
au bout des 48 heures de garde à vue
libéré sans charge en l'état et où
seront peut-être convoqué ultérieurement
par le juge d'instruction pour d'autres
auditions et pour les besoins de
l'instruction
monsieur cédric jubile arts a donc été
présenté aujourd'hui devant les deux
juges d'instruction cosaisis il a été
mis en examen je vous le confirme
puisque il semble que celles déjà été
diffusés qu'il a été mis en examen pour
homicide volontaire par conjoint et ils
viennent d'être placés sous mandat de
dépôt par le juge des libertés de la
détention de toulouse
sur saisine du juge d'instruction et sur
les réquisitions conforme du parquet de
toulouse dans le cadre de cette
instruction
je tenais aussi avant d'engager vraiment
mon propos a insisté sur le fait que
monsieur julia avec son avocat conteste
sur l'implication dans cette affaire y
compris dans sa qualification actuelle
est donc il aura effectivement à
développer sa défense avec l'assistance
de sonde ses conseils et dans le cadre
bien sûr du respect de la présomption
d'innocence
je vous ai rappelé le cheminement
procédurale de ces dossiers
je voudrais
rappeler très brièvement les faits bruts
tels qu'ils ont été portés à la
connaissance la gendarmerie du tarn le
16 décembre dernier 4h09 très
précisément le centre opérationnel de
gendarmerie du tarn et été avisé par un
coup de téléphone de monsieur cédric
julia du fait qu' il venait il avait
constaté la disparition de son épouse
alors qu'il avait été réveillé par les
pleurs de sa fille âgée de 18 mois de
leur fille âgée de 18 mois
vers 3h45 il avait alors cherché
vainement sur les pouilles dans la
maison ne l'avait pas trouvé avait donné
quelques coups de fil et sinon 16
minutes plus tard très précisément
puisqu'il repart connaître en marche son
portable à 3h54 il va contacter la
gendarmerie la gendarmerie donc qui va
immédiatement sous l'autorité du colonel
si présent intervenir sérieux va arriver
à 4h50
il va effectivement constaté cette
disparition qui apparaît comme
immédiatement une disparition
inquiétante et malgré des moyens très
importants vous emparer colonel tout à
l'heure qui ont été immédiatement
mobilisées par landry dans les heures et
les jours qui ont suivi cette
disparition a donné lieu à l'ouverture
de cette enquête disparition est
inquiétante et d'autre part à convient
donc le sort procédural que je vous
rappeler tout à l'heure ce qui est
important aussi de noter c'est que
la personne disparue
avec est partie en tout cas disparu avec
son téléphone portable téléphone
portable qui a fonctionné jusqu'à 22
heures 55
oui c'est ça 22h57 la veille et en fait
passera en messagerie à 7h48 très
précisément pour ne plus jamais être
donc activer ou recharger j'ai noté
effectivement que monsieur j villa avec
l'a6 tout seul qui après des glacis
stands et gendarmes va effectivement
tenté de contacter à de multiples
reprises son épouse puisque à peu près
180 appel jusqu'à au lendemain matin
jusqu'à 1000 une entrevue jusque vers 10
heures et puis depuis il en ait erreurs
on n'a recensé que deux à peine c'est à
dire qu'à partir du 16 et du maine du 17
au matin il n'y aura plus jamais d'appel
sur ce sur ce téléphone qui n'a toujours
pas été retrouvée d'ailleurs ce que je
voulais vous dire aussi c'est que dans
ce cadre là monsieur gilles vilard a
fourni des explications qui sont
qualifiés par les enquêteurs et les
magistrats instructeurs et - vie à juste
titre d'explication qui ont été pour le
moins évolutive pour ne pas dire
contradictoire est compris entre l
interne et parfois par des témoignages
ou des éléments scientifiques et
objectifs qui ont été établis et sont
versés au dossier et même par bon sens
puisque lui-même a évolué y compris au
cours de sa garde à vue sur plusieurs
points et dans différentes déclarations
tout en continuant et je le répète a
contesté les faits qui lui sont imputés
aujourd'hui on va venir l'examen des
éléments qui ont conduit à cette garde à
vue puis à cette mise en examen
je voulais effectivement resituer cette
disparition
cette disparition vous l'avez compris la
détecter les kings inquiétante des
débuts pourquoi parce qu'il n'est pas
normal qu'une mère de famille mère de
deux ans
disparaissent en pleine nuit en décembre
dans la nuit du 15 au 16 décembre 2020
nous sommes je vous le rappelle en
confinant dans un petit village qu'elle
est appelée ligne où il ya très peu de
passage où il fait froid où les
conditions climatiques sont mauvaises et
puis surtout c'est une personne qui va
partir avec eux si l'on en croit ce qui
nous est dit en tout cas ça disparaît
avec un téléphone sans charger mais
aussi sans son sac à main
sans aucun sans aucun effet personnel
sans ses lunettes dont elle a besoin
sans non plus prendre le crayon véhicule
qui lui appartient et qu'elle conduit
puisque même s'il le fait habituellement
monsieur gélinas n'est pas titulaire du
permis de conduire et donc disparaître
complètement
c'est une disparition qui effectivement
de ce point de vue là est tout à fait
inquiétant
il a été établi aussi c'est une
disparition qui est coûteux qui ne
saurait être considéré comme volontaire
c'est un élément j'avais pris en compte
au moment de l'ouverture d'information
parce que c'est apparu très vite mon
colonel
au vu des multiples actes que vous aviez
jean king qui a été validée ensuite dans
la poursuite des investigations
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que vous
avez déjà là l'exemple il travail
considérable qui a été accompli c'est à
dire que la thèse de la chute de
l'accident a été évacué
parce que le fait de partir dans la nuit
comme ça avec un téléphone quand on sait
que le
dans l'ordre thorfinn n'a pas été
activée dont aussi qu'il appartient à
une personne qui n'aime pas sortir dans
le noir qui n'a pas de raison de sortir
à ce moment-là et déjà un point
particulièrement inquiétant donc su tout
accident expliquera ce non seulement aux
battues et aussi au travail exceptionnel
de ratissage fait sur des kilomètres et
des kilomètres carrés avec des plongeurs
des hélicoptères des drones des radars
des sombres qui ont fait qu'ils n'ont
jamais permis justement de retrouver
cette personne
de même la notion même de suicide ou de
départs volontaires dans les conditions
décrites de manière aussi brusque est en
contradiction totale avec tous les
éléments du dossier
vous le savez madame madame delphine aux
gaines épouse de gilles vilard était
donc une mère de famille une infirmière
qui adorait son métier était très
apprécié par ses collègues ils ont
encore manifesté récemment car et les
amis des proches qui la soutenaient
qu'ils adorent et ses enfants et n'avait
strictement aucune raison alors que l
préparer les fêtes de noël et et qu'il
n'y avait aucun problème de ce point de
vue là de disparaître et notamment dans
donnant ses enfants
et puis surtout aussi au delà de sa vie
familiale
elle avait aussi vous le savez un projet
puisque le couple était en voie de
séparation et que wallemme julliard
avait effectivement le projet dans les
semaine qui suivait de quitter
définitivement le domicile de
s'installer avec notre homme qu'elle
avait rencontré l'été précédent et à cet
égard
en plus elle avait engagé des démarches
qui vont en totale contradiction avec
une telle disparition puisque elle avait
pris un crédit pour acheter une voiture
elle faisait des recherches de logement
notamment sur albi à mon souvenir
elle avait la sécurité de son emploi
elle avait acheté des meubles etc etc
donc c'est un projet qui de vie nouveau
nouvelle qui lui qui lui tenait à coeur
et elle avait d'ores et déjà semble-t-il
au vu des éléments des multiples témoins
j'ai décidé de quitter son époux il y
avait même engagé une procédure de
divorce pour pouvoir justement avoir
cette nouvelle vie avec ses enfants et
en quittant cette maison qui aurait été
laissée donc à son mari lequel part
d'une part un son le caractère parfois
aléatoire de ces emplois une
consommation importante aussi de
produits stupéfiants qui est très cher
et ses besoins financiers auraient été
incapables effectivement d'assurer la
continuité du paiement des échéances de
ce domicile donc en homo aucune raison
aucune raison objective humaines
matérielles affective de partir dans ces
conditions alors que des projets sont là
qu'ils prennent forme et qu'il prenne
corps confronté à ces éléments
monsieur gilles vilard nous expliquera
d'abord que est juste ici qu'en réalité
cette séparation finalement se passer de
manière non conflictuelle qui s'était
même rapproché récemment que
faisait chambre à part mais que cela
n'empêchait pas effectivement des
échanges réguliers entre eux et d'autre
part que
il ignorer que sur les pousses voulait
quitter pour une autre
le problème c'est que l'ensemble des
éléments réunis les témoignages et les
investigations ont permis d'établir que
ces déclarations étaient complètement
mensongères et je reviendrai tout
d'ailleurs sur la prégnance du conflit
sur la séparation qui peut être relevée
presque de l'ordre du mobile avant de
revenir à ces éléments concernant
directement
monsieur gilles vilard je voulais aussi
dire que les allées les enquêteurs ont
travaillé de manière jaillir négative
dire ce qu on dit dans le jargon fermer
les portes
ils ont commencé par prendre l'hypothèse
d'un enlèvement puisque c'était bien la
qualification qui était retenue donc un
travail énorme a été fait en ce qui
concerne la circulation aux abords de ce
village de recherche de rôdeur recherche
de délinquant sexuel consultation des
fichiers au niveau de la région contrôle
routier paix aux péages d'autoroutes
dans les heures et les jours qui ont
suivi qui ont été multipliés donc le
rôdeur a été écartée
ensuite
les recherches sont concentrées sur des
gens qui connaissaient vous fréquentez
vous avez pu côtoyer madame l'os gagnent
là aussi en premier chef sur maman a été
définitivement mis hors de cause il
était à 100 km le soir des faits de la
même manière ce qui aurait qu'un bus
complètement paradoxale puisque aller
s'installer avec lui on a fait aussi le
tour de ses relations passées ou deux
personnes qui avaient pu effectivement
l'approché et cetera qui est aussi mon
colonel
et pour plusieurs ont été ont été mis
hors de cause de manière
j'allais dire irréfutable par des
éléments à la fois de personnes de
constatations et d'éléments techniques
il est quand même aussi révélateur que
la garde à vue a été fixée le 16
décembre et le colonel me rappelait tout
à l'heure que le qu'elle descend encore
il recevait en retour des éléments très
importants d'un point de vue technique
qui mettait hors de cause un certain
nombre de personnes sur lesquelles il
n'avait pu il avait pu enquêter et y
compris d'ailleurs sur certaines
déclarations de monsieur gilles vilard
suis même si c'est pas lui c'est d'y
aller voir de ce côté et c'est ça donc
été fait reste que désormais au vu des
éléments je vais vous exposer ses biens
l'hypothèse d'une disparition criminels
qui est retenu et y est privilégiée avec
toute conséquence sur les besoins de
l'instruction qui va se poursuivre et
dont le point le point focal reste
effectivement la recherche de la
découverte des madame nomades annonce
qu'elle épouse jubilaire qui va se
continuer bien sûr au rythme que je vous
ai indiqué tout à l'heure et qui est
vraiment de très haut niveau avec
l'investissement tout aussi important
des magistrats instructeurs
c'est tout vu au vu de tous ces éléments
jaillir négatif qui a eu cette évolution
est cette garde à vue
l' hypothèse d'heure mais qui n'est pas
une hypothèse mais en réalité
l'analyse qui est faite au niveau de ces
2002 ce 2002 quote c'est
qu'effectivement on se trouve sur une
présomption d'homicide de à l'encontre
de cette personne est ce qu en l'état
mesdames le juge d'instruction sur leur
vision conformes ont estimé qu' il
existe et il dut suffisant pour qu'il
soit mal le matérialiser par la mise en
examen qui a été notifié aujourd'hui de
monsieur cédric je vis là je vais aller
à l'essentiel dorénavant en vous
rappelant d'abord que s'agissant du du
couple jubilaire contrairement à ce qui
a été dit et soutenu y compris par
l'intéressé ce contexte de séparation
était très conflictuelle et donné lieu à
de fréquentes disputes
ce qui est bien expliquée par l'ensemble
des témoins de la famille c'est qu'en
réalité c'est de djezzy leur avait une
très grande difficulté au point de vue
affectif matériel a accepté cette
séparation la vivait très mal tenté même
au conquet sur les pouces mais une
manière particulièrement intrusive et
agressive puisqu'il pouvait se montrer
brutal aussi agressif dupont pris envers
ses enfants et il y avait organisé ça
c'est ça l'unité évoqué dans certains
articles à quelque temps véritable
surveillance de son épouse
l'interrogeant sur ses déplacements
allant sur son sur son compte pour voir
si elle avait effectivement fait des
dépenses essayant même de la géocache
géolocalisés et donc étant très très
intrusif dans la façon dont justement
son épouse
organiser progressivement leur
séparation ce qui est acquis c'est
qu'après l'avoir nié après avoir fourni
plusieurs déclarations c'est que
dorénavant monsieur jubilaire convient
qu'il était parfaitement au courant du
fait que sur les poses à des noms et
l'ensemble image confirme donc le que
c'était quelque chose de très
conflictuelles comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure
y compris au niveau matériel en ce qui
le concerne et est enterré très attaché
à cette maison n'ayant pas les moyens
donc de l'entretenir sur le déroulement
déchets tels que de la soirée tels que a
pu le décrire c'est régis le billard et
sur les constatations faites par les
enquêteurs il y a là des indices qui ont
conduit justement à cette mise en examen
je vous le rappelle la version qui a
évolué c'était je me suis couché vers
22h30
je me suis réveillé vers 3h45 ma main ma
femme était sortie promener les chiens
ont certainement et mon fils vers 23h et
elle est allée se coucher après avoir
regardé la télévision fils âgé de 6 ans
au demeurant le problème si vous vouliez
que dans le cadre de cette de cette
description da toute une série
d'éléments qui sont venus infirmer ces
déclarations auxquelles monsieur jubile
en a répondu par des adaptations des
contradictions voire même des mensonges
sort des faits lorsque les gendarmes se
présentent sur place ils sont
interpellés par plusieurs choses la
première c'est que monsieur julliard
lorsqu'il donne l'alertent alors qu'il
avait passé en août précédant même où sa
femme s'est endormi à l'extérieur où il
ya des simplement appeler des années
jamais appelé la gendarmerie
c'est que là il va faire très très vite
puisque 16 minutes pour appeler lâchant
à la gendarmerie bon de concevoir qu'il
soit inquiet mais on constate que
finalement les amis proches notamment
les meilleurs amis ou la famille n'a pas
été directement contacté guy seulement
quelques coups de téléphone
ça n'est qu'après qui a effectivement
sous très bon nombre d'appels qui
resteront sans réponses qui sont passés
et lorsque les gendarmes aride puisqu'il
expose qu'il a cherché sa fin mais qu'
il ay les a appelés le podomètre puisque
tout est important le podomètre de son
téléphone était allumée lorsque les
gendarmes sont arrivés ils avaient fait
l'équivalent de 40 pas ce qu'ils font
fait de recherche d'amis qui sont au
sommaire alors que avec les gendarmes
lorsqu'il va tourner sur la propriété et
dans les domiciles ses 380 pas qu'ils
vont être le ton qu'il ya des recherches
qui finalement sont tassées en sommet à
qui sont enregistrées
le deuxième élément c'est que monsieur
gilles harb a beaucoup d'envié sur les
vêtements et la tenue que portait son
épouse lorsque il prétend être allé se
coucher et qu'elle même restée ignorée
même sorti les chiens puisqu'il parle
une fois d'une doudoune avec des boots
et puis une autre fois il parle d'une
chimie serait sur un pyjama et paix quel
horaire d'été alors que sa femme n'est
pas d'étude de sortir le soir qu'elle ne
provenait jamais les chiens que ce n'est
plus peu puisque c'était plutôt les dix
salles occupées que les enfants étaient
au lit et que cette dame qui travaille
et je pense de 23h avait peut-être
plutôt envie d'aller se reposer ce
qu'elle te revient aussi c'est que
lorsque les gendarmes arrivent vers
donc 4h50 il trouve monsieur jubilaire
occupé à déclencher une machine machine
à laver dans lequel se trouve la couette
du glee sur lequel dormait madame jubila
ceci se passe de manière dans un
contexte dont conviendrait assez
incongrue puisqu'elle a disparu mais ce
n'est pas pour plaire à pas la première
chose à laquelle on pense d'autant plus
que je suis désolé de le dire mais que
ça se situe dans une habitation dont
l'état d'entretien est extrêmement
négligé et on ne voit pas l'intérêt 1
puisque monsieur j la rue même et dans
un pyjama était et vêtu d'un pyjama dont
il explique qu'il a jamais avec la sous
faure la expliquant que ce serait
peut-être les chiens qui aurait sali
c'était de litres d'eau donc il était en
train de le laver ce qui a quatre heures
4h50 du matin n'est pas forcément la
première chose à laquelle on pense
lorsque votre femme a disparu
mais là encore c'est un élément objectif
sur lequel bon cette réponse est celle
que monsieur gillard a fait ensuite il
va très rapidement donner les clés du
véhicule je vous rappellerai pas permis
mais surtout il a les données
effectivement aux enquêteurs et les
enquêteurs à part travers les
témoignages qui vont être recueillie
progressivement vont comprendre en plus
qu'il ya un problème sur ce véhicule
puisque ce véhicule qui appartient à son
épouse qui est donc seraient partis à
pied sans sucre et sans rien sans qu'un
document ce véhicule il est établi que
deux choses il est établi qu il a été
déplacé
c'est à dire que madame gillard avait
ses habitudes elle en été dans le sens
de la montée
toujours prêt pour le départ le
lendemain dans un sens précis et les
voisins ont confirmé que lorsqu'elle est
arrivée le 15 décembre soir elle l'avait
garée comme à l'habitude lorsque les
gendarmes
en 50 arrivent la voiture est garée dans
l'autre sens deuxième élément ce
véhicule qui n'avait pas été fouillé
d'après ses dires par monsieur villareal
et par les gendarmes
un seul véhicule à la porte d'à la part
dont la vitre du côté conducteur qui est
à moitié ouverte et surtout qui a de la
présence de condensation à l'intérieur
du véhicule nous sommes la nuit du 15 au
16 décembre
un expert spécialiste a été requis et il
a expliqué que en fait cette
condensation correspondait vu les
conditions
jules leleu le leur le lieu etc
à
au fait qu'il aurait été peu il devait
être ok par une présence humaine dans ce
véhicule c'est de la condensation est
bon ce véhicule on n'a pas établi si
c'était déplacé en l'état mais n'empêche
qu'il a été changée que ses clés ont été
donnés avec une grande rapidité et en
plus donc qu'il ya eu cette modification
j'ajouterai aussi qu' il n'y a pas de
sens qui a été trouvé sur les lieux lors
des différentes investigations mais de
ce point de vue là le déroulé des faits
lui même reste encore à parfaitement
déterminé cette déranger bien sûr de
l'instruction qui va se poursuivre je
voulais rajouter pour terminer deux
choses la première c'est que en ce qui
concerne les déclarations de monsieur
gilles wiart il soutient encore
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a pas une dispute
ce soir là que tout s'est bien passé qui
sont allés se coucher que donc appris
s'est réveillé les enquêteurs ont émis
deux éléments qui sont à mon avis
important en tant qu'élément objectif à
soumettre justement l'appréciation de
monsieur jubila le premier c'est que son
fils vivait six ans qui a été entendu a
fait des déclarations selon lesquelles
vers 23 heures
lorsqu'il va se coucher après avoir fait
un câlin à sa mère il entend entrer dans
sa chambre alors qu'il est réveillé une
violente dispute entre les parents c'est
un témoignage qui me paraît crédible
parce que dans le même temps cet enfant
c'est un ensemble de six ans il faut pas
oublier cet enfant si que sa maman est
avec un monsieur
il le dit il la même
il une vision il a vu par vision ils ont
eu des échanges il a accompagné sa mère
lors de certaines de certains échanges
qui pouvait se faire de manière
dématérialisée et avec toute l'innocence
de l'enfant de six ans il dira à son
père que bon on a vu le monsieur mais
que c'est un secret d'un moment et
publiera pas donc ça me paraît quand
même crédible parce que tout ce que je
vous dis là est avérée par ailleurs
puisque effectivement il y avait ce qui
n'était pas il ya d'ailleurs un secret
les sept enfants avait vu avait compris
et il est formel sur le fait que ses
parents se sont violemment disputés ce
soir là le mise en examen conteste dit
que cette enfance une fils doit
confondre avec d'autres soirées même si
aujourd'hui reconnaît que pour une
séparation qui se passait très bien
il admet qu'il ya pu être brutal
grossier et bousculer son épouse dans le
cadre de leurs fréquentes disputes
puisqu'elles sont avérées au maintenant
et puis au même moment juste après 23
heures
les enquêteurs ont déterminé de manière
formelle que deux voisines une mère et
sa fille havel 3h07 très précisément
après des investigations auprès des
médias justement parce que c'était pas
référence à une émission une coupure
publicitaire on a pu dire que cette
belle 3h07 très précisément cette dame
est cette fille donc un adulte vont
entendre en direction du domicile des de
la famille du billard des cris stridents
et de détresse d'une femme qui vont
effectivement les interpeller équipes
ont progressivement
donc disparaître et s'arrêter dans la
nuit ce qui ne les a pas outre mesure
excité puisqu'elles n'ont pas pensé
appeler les gendarmes à ce moment là est
en tout cas ce sont des éléments qui
sont à timon dossier et auxquelles
monsieur billardon donne pas de réponses
me semble-t-il crédible puisque lui-même
a expliqué que ne voulait pas faire des
recherches dans le jardin vos inventions
domicile pour pas déranger les voisins
alors qu' il y reçoit des plaintes
régulières sur le bruit que font ces
chiens qui d'ailleurs ce soir là à la
même heure était dehors et envoyer très
violemment comme on peut entendre un
effectivement des chiens lorsque les
propriétaires du truc ce peuvent
effectivement donc être excité aussi est
il est vrai que les chiens étaient
restés dehors
cette nuit là j'ajouterai pour terminer
que cette instruction elle va aussi
s'attacher
bien sûr je me disais à poursuivre ses
recherches à continuer les multiples
actes qui sont encore en cours a
clarifié étayer ces éléments sous la
direction des juges d'instruction qui
auront aussi à mon avis à se pencher de
manière importante sur la personnalité
de la personne qui désormais est mise en
examen non obstant la présomption
d'innocence devra dorénavant s'expliquer
devant le juge d'instruction dans la
mesure où ce qui a été constaté c'est
finalement je crois que ç'a déjà été
pointée dans certains articles une
personnalité qu'il héritera expertise
parce que ce qui ressort c'est
finalement une une forme de déni très
rapidement c'est pas forcément une
charge mais c'est simplement un constat
et ça peut être ça traduit peut-être une
psychologie à défaut date il ya eu un
déni du très rapide
le fait de parler très rapidement de son
épouse au passé de se concentrer sur ses
propres difficultés et le fait d'enfants
aussi rapidement une vie affective
puisque j'ai cru comprendre qu'une
personne avec laquelle il avait une
relation qui a été entendu par les
gendarmes s'est aussi confiée à certains
médias
au passage d'ailleurs en me disant en
déclarant puisque je parlais au début
d'une information parcellaire sommes
exactes en présentant une version de la
situation
assez éloigné de ce qu'elle a pu
raconter devant les gendarmes sous
serment
il se peut donc madame instruction
besoin d'entendre cette personne voilà
les éléments concordants sur le contexte
sur le déroulé de la soirée sur les
peler les éléments qui ont pu être
qu'ils ont pu être constitués sur toutes
ces incohérences qui ont conduit à
orienter les investigations vers
monsieur eric gillard a provoqué son
interpellation puis sa mise en examen
je souhaite que messieurs les connais
depuis sont complétées sur les moyens
sur la d investigation et puis après
tout nous répondront ensemble de
questions là encore peut-être pour
dissiper parce que vous en avez compté
beaucoup vous qui domine est
parfaitement et depuis le début le
dossier auquel je n'avais pas accès
jusqu'à récemment ce qui me concerne sur
le certaines informations qui méritent
auront peut-être envie de vos questions
à être précisés voir infirmer ou
confirmer parce que beaucoup de choses
ont été dites et la réalité justement et
celle avec elle moi je me borne c'est
celle du dossier on connaît
rapprochez-vous simplement pour dire que
des moyens très importants ont été
déployés par la gendarmerie nationale
dans le cadre de ce dossier
d'abord dans le cas des recherches
opérationnelles qui ont été conduites
par essentiellement par le groupement de
gendarmerie du du temps puisque c'est
une centaine de militaires qui ont été
engagées pendant des dix premiers jours
de la disparition il ya eu des
ratissages sur un périmètre de plus de
10 kilomètres autour du domicile de
monsieur madame jubila parallèlement
évidemment il ya les enquêtes
judiciaires qui a été engagée et donc
dans le cadre de l'information
judiciaire c'est une cellule nationale
d' enquête qui a été mise sur pied par
la gendarmerie qui était armé par dix
enquêteurs qui à temps plein ont mené
les investigations au cours des six
derniers mois
et comme on le fait habituellement dans
ce dossier là on a établi des hypothèses
et ensuite on s'est attaché les unes
après les autres a fermé chacune de ces
hypothèses et ces après avoir fermé
l'ensemble des hypothèses qu'avec les
magistrats instructeurs
nous avons décidé mercredi de passer en
phase opérationnelle et donc
d'interpeller monsieur jubila et son sa
maman et son beau père voilà sur les sur
des sur les moyens
ce que je peux dire sachant que en appui
évidemment on a utilisé tous les moyens
techniques dont nous disposons que ce
soit moyens aériens moyens subaquatique
moyens techniques en particulier avec
dire cgn le pôle judiciaire de pontoise
pas tous les moyens dont nous pouvons
disposer au niveau national régional ont
été mis en oeuvre dans ce dossier
7 les investigations étaient conduites
par le groupement dans un premier temps
on était un peu partout vous également
puisque les attendus également avec vous
une certaine manière l'appui de la
population et il a pas échappé dans 13
des 16 2
la population tarnaise des habitants de
cagnac était partiellement présenter des
gendarmes
il a fallu donc cette première phase
outre les recherches opérationnelles et
les moyens quand est déployée outre les
investigations qui ont été conduites sur
cette première semaine parce que mon
discernement et pour élargir le secteur
de recherche puis le blason dans
laquelle nous ont été engagés il a fallu
également intégrer ce volet
de présence de la population et de bonne
volonté à orienter à canaliser et afin
de permettre d'utiliser cette ressource
ces personnes mais également de ne pas
contrevenir au bon déroulement on a
retrouvé ensuite
cette particularité qui était d'avoir à
nos côtés où on a toutes ces
investigations
la population permet cependant toujours
sur leur sort merci bon caudle est-ce
que vous avez des questions
mouss errements
la sympathique mais on découvre
maraîchers qui la somme qu'ils ont
constaté les gendarmes arrivent à 4h50
on est bien d'accord on répondu
en fait les militaires du groupement du
tarn qui sont engagés par le centre
opérationnel après l'appel de monsieur
jules bizarre qui signale la disparition
son épouse quand il arrive au domicile à
4h50
monsieur gilles viard est en train de
mettre une machine à laver et dans
tambour de machine à laver est en fait
la couette qui en fait est sûre le le
canapé du salon canapé sur lequel dort
habituellement son épouse avec laquelle
il est en voie de séparation ce qui est
comme le disait de ce procureur de la
république
assez étonnant compte tenu dans le
groupe vaccin et le déroulé des lampes m
alors les gens là quand ils
interviennent à 4h50 du matin ils
interviennent avec les informations très
parcellaire qu'ils ont obtenu et donc il
n'ya pas à ce moment-là de soupçons à
l'encontre de monsieur cédric jubila
donc c'est dans un second temps que on
va intervenir sur cette machine à laver
en fait la couette entre temps a été
retiré la machine à laver par contre on
aura on fera des des analyses en
particulier sur le siphon de la machine
à laver mais là moi je peux pas aller au
delà en s'arrêtant brute de là compte
tenu de la confidentialité des
investigations c'était simplement pour
rappeler que lorsque les gendarmes
arrivent
il ya finalement peu de recherches qui
ont été engagés d'un point de vue
physique pour essayer de retrouver cette
personne au sein de la maison puisque en
tout et pour tout il ya 40 patrons et
fsu en comptant le rez-de-chaussée les
étages le sous sol il n'est pas il dit
qu'il veut pas aller à l'extérieur pour
pas dérangé qui n'a pas regardé s'il
était de voir ou ailleurs il le fera
avec les gendarmes et de manière
beaucoup plus longue et appui je ne dis
pas que c'est une une cohérence et un
constat objectif
qu'en est il des vaccinations de là
je sais qu'on a beaucoup parlé du
colonel vous aviez vraiment technique
c'est une tumeur 96 puis 9 c'est une
réactivation qui tient lieu de se dédire
provoqué un certain temps incertain dans
une certaine mesure à partir de
tentative de reconstitution d'éléments
pour permettre de localiser de trouver
le téléphone est en réalité elle s'est
déclenchée samedi sur un bug technique
qu'il a depuis ne s'est pas renouvelé
les celtes et confirmé par les
fabricants ou hébergeurs mais c'était un
travail de technique pour vous l'avez
compris recherché ce téléphone que la
parole est pas forcément vu il y avait
un travail qui a été fait mais le
déclenchement n'était pas dans ces
circonstances tokyo déclic
ces deux techniques et ça parce qu'on
justement au travail anses a pu
déclencher mais cet élément qui
malheureusement on n'a pas n'a pas pu
être exploités ultérieurement en tout
cas pas à ce stade il n'y a pas un
moment justement directement la
découverte de cet appareil existe ici
une photo soit en effet photos sur le
crecq ça ferait plutôt à dormir faute
repreneur photo condiments tournée nous
endormir ah non c'est pas ça va voulait
me dire avant d'aller dans non je pense
que la gale une erreur qui a été fait
récemment
il n'y a pas de photos de villars pour
être très clair sur les informations qui
sont parfois très récemment dans le
téléphone monsieur série du billard
cette photo d'elle et le soir parce
qu'elle va être tout au tout
une long moment dans la soirée elle va
échanger avec cette personne et c'est
pour ça qu on a une faim de connexion
qui est extrêmement précise
je crois qu'à peine 2 heures 50 ou 55
voilà ici à une photo qui a été renvoyé
on a certainement pas
voyez à son parti en voyage sur les pas
sont encore dans des horaires qui sont
encore en début de soirée le plateau ça
peut constituer un modèle
moi je vous ai dis simplement ce portal
appréciation sur les charges je vous ai
donné les éléments objectifs qui sont en
mesure d'être rendues publiques
c'est-à-dire vous rappeler que ce
soir-là d'être moins d'ipad d'une
violente dispute on vous préciser ce que
vous avez
pendant cette garde le lagarde fut elle
aussi été découverte mais dans le cadre
de cette garde à vue
monsieur julien maintenu ses dénégations
et a fourni des explications qui au fur
et à mesure des éléments qui lui étaient
soumis par les enquêteurs était
évolutive en contradiction avec un
certain nombre d'éléments objectifs et
agréé qui soit technique ou humain et
ont conduit d'ailleurs à la personne
gardée à vue a évolué lui-même dans ses
déclarations
quand il disait par exemple que c'était
sa femme qui avait sorti les chiens dans
le dernier indice est ressorti voyez
donc il ya une série d'évolutions mais
sur le fond du dossier
si j'ai bien on reconnaît pas son
implication dans les faits il a été
confronté à ses nerfs il ya eu des
explications aussi du beau père qui l'a
enfin trouvée nantes dans le cadre du
secret de l'instruction
mais qui n'ont pas si c'est ça compte de
mendier a mené à une évolution décisive
ou désaveu si c'est ça que je voulais
que j'ai pris la précaution de vous dire
au début son point de presse que ces
faits a été contestée tant par une
personne vit à l'examen que personnel
le monde
moi j'ai j'identifie ricci racing
merci à monsieur ses songes instruction
avec des enquêteurs qui densifie
le motif de la dispute s'est lassé s'il
ya eu dispute et les éléments qu'on a me
laisse penser
elle était récurrente à ce sujet elle
est la porte est certainement sur la
situation et sur les relations au sein
du couple cette séparation avant non
parce qu'avant le téléphone est éteint
mais la boîte il a le droit de mentir
c'est sa défense est bien de droit de
d'évoluer dans ces déclarations le c'est
pour ça que je ne fais aucun commentaire
sur ses propres déclarations
je m'en tiens des éléments qui ont été
objective et il validé par les juges
d'instruction il a reconnu qu'il
connaissait l'existence de l'amant
est ce que les
j'espère que vous en pensez à
reconnaître l'évidence les éléments
matériels qui montrait qu'il s est
vraiment ça a été ça a été déjà établi
avant et je ne peux pas répondre très
précisément parce que c'est dans le
cadre de la garde à vue avec sa i télé
le prix sous l'autorité des juges
d'instruction mais je peux quand même
dire qu'il ya eu une évolution de ce
point de vue là dans la version qui
était présente
et tout simplement parce que ces deux là
voilà parce qu'il est ils ont émergé dès
le lendemain me servir de la disparition
et que l'information
il y avait des informations à recueillir
sur des impressions des échanges
des convictions pour avoir les uns des
autres sur la situation
on a un
avec si vous voulez depuis sa
disparition aussi du point de vue de mon
jubilé à un dénigrement de son épouse
partagé aussi par certains membres de sa
famille y compris dans son comportement
maternel qui était pourtant l'apport de
toute critique loin de là et il fallait
donc les entends puisqu'il a et que
depuis un moment et les enquêteurs comme
les juges d'instruction les styles et
que ça devait se faire dans ce cadre je
pense même que des confrontations qui
sont maintenant entre les mains des
juges d'instruction qui auront
certainement des actes de nouvelles
auditions interrogatoires et
confrontations que des trains développer
dans les prochaines semaines prochains
mois puisque c'est un aussi vous avez
compris c'est un aboutissement one de là
c'est une évolution importante
les investigations vont se poursuivre de
manière tout aussi diligente et en
hommes et en moyens dit faux puisque
nous recherchons une personne que à
partir de là tous les moyens humains et
matériels possible doivent être
mobilisés tout simplement parce qu'il
s'agit vous l'avez compris c'est notre
devoir d'essayer de rechercher la vérité
la vraie vérité des faits et du dossier
dans le cadre de cette instance
judiciaire
[Musique]
parution
parfaitement connaissance de l'essentiel
c'est monsieur guillon ne présente pas
les choses comme ça ils dansent à
convenir qu'il ya que se tromper où il a
vécu comprendre savoir mais il a
maintenant des réponses qui sont
franches puisque lui-même parfois se
contredit mais c'est une charge je vous
le répète une personne qui conteste les
faits le droit bien sûr de ses mentors
d'exprimer sa propre vision des choses
sa version des faits est au contraire de
répondre aux enquêteurs quand ils le
souhaitent et en l'occurrence avec
systématiquement assistance de ce
déplacement
check it and see reconnaître majetel il
souriait nom n'a pu dire ça l'a su il ya
pu dire que de toute manière je suis
jean rède aussi le suspect d'une horreur
si tu n'arrives jours qu'ils attendaient
il était possible que viennent lui
demander des explications autre part que
des simples auditions de témoins deux
parties civiles comme ça a été le cas le
30 mai dernier
donc ce que vous confirmez que vous ai
dit tout à l'heure que le lundi 15 il ya
encore eu des éléments très importants
dont étaient reçus par les enquêteurs
qui ont provoqué justement c'est les
mains parce qu'en fait toutes les
investigations par la noblesse de cette
idée de fermer les portes de mettre hors
de cause telle ou telle personne tel ou
tel témoignage table des situations bien
ça se fait au jour d'aujourd'hui dit
tout à l'heure de 1500 actes ils le
j'étais mal dans la soirée il rallume et
il a été éteint par ma soirée au moins
deux traitant du calq y être allé se
coucher et il a rallumé très précisément
je voulais dire quinze minutes avant
l'appel
alors les enfants avait été confiée je
crois la grand-mère et bon gars mais le
travail a été fait il a été fait au
niveau juste les enfants du tribunal
judiciaire d'acquis quelques et saisit
immédiatement je prends mon modèle par
le parquet d'albi comme il se doit
il ya donc une assistance éducative qui
est en place pour ses deux enfants de 6
ans de 18 mois et dans le dernier état
mais des sons réserve effectivement des
décisions du juge des enfants auxquels
je peux pas je peux pas me substituer
il semblerait que les entendre confié un
autre membre de la famille je crois la
soeur de jean jé billard ont tout là je
pense que les la grand mère
mais là encore je ne peux pas anticiper
parce que je vous le répète le juste
devant son baby et que le dit aussi de
protection des victimes et des enfants a
été mis en place
donc décidera effectivement aussi du
lieu de placement et des conditions de
suivi qui seront réalisés pour ses deux
enfants mineurs
scénario lui reste
alors là il ya deux a priori le premier
c'est que vous êtes en train de dire
qu'il ait tué sa femme je n'ai pas 10 en
examen bien l'examen par an dernier de
vendre pour la 6 nous ne sommes pas
examiné des charges
nous sommes à examiner des indices
graves et concordants qui ont justifié
une décision de mise à médecins et de
patients sous mandat de dépôt et qui t'a
dit c'est donc à cette personne la
possibilité de développer comme je le
disais sa défense avec les conseils de
son avocat moi je c'est pour ça que j'en
parlais aussi twitter je ne parle que
des éléments objectifs une parle pas de
scénario je ne fais pas de commentaires
sur les charges
il y à un certain nombre d'hypothèses
qui ont été pour être plus précis
examinez systématiquement par les
gendarmes depuis le début qui ont été
écartés et on en arrive effectivement à
cette convergence mains d'éléments
mettant en cause justement la personne
sur sept il y avait tous les droits qui
lui sont attachés c'est tout l'intérêt
justement de l'instruction je conclus
tout à l'heure là dessus c'est de
rechercher la vérité
vous savez qu'il ya énormément de choses
qui ont été faites moi j'ai c'est pour
ça que j'ai commencé par qui a mis des
fêtes
c'est pour ça que j'ai commencé par ça
parce que c'est le cas des leçons
comment c'est pas les écoutes
téléphoniques ne sais pas ne rentrons
pas de téléphone
c'est de rechercher et de retrouver
cette personne disparue cette neige
cette attaque survient c'est vraiment
très apprécié il est devant elle
respectivement vie
auquel chacun a droit c'est surtout ça
qui me préoccupe ce dossier et pour le
reste je voulais dire je vous ai
justement souligné l'importance des
moyens qui ont été développés
continueront d'être mobilisés dans le
cadre de ce dossier
n'imaginez pas de vérification sur saône
et ya pas longtemps pour vous donner un
exemple il savourait une meuf sont deux
j'allais dire d'apaisement sait aussi
c'est que je te dis sur les réseaux
sociaux comme je me devais d'être un
d'espagne aux réalités craighead essec
etc
je vais vous indiqué sans autre
précision les gendarmes ont fait les
précisions on a effectivement trouvé le
new morning
mais qui n'a le responsable d'un
catherine au sénat pour vous dire que
nous portons les investigations se
poursuivront sans relâche jusqu'au bout
de ce temps cuire jusqu'à ce qu'
effectivement comme vous deviez peur
monsieur un scénario qu'il vérité
judiciaire et et y ait effectivement je
vais dire un travail de continuer
jusqu'à ce que
puissions savoir ce qu'il s'est passé et
retrouver cette personne disparue et en
six mois il ya moins de 8 ans
je crois mon conem les autorités
vérifient malheureusement si vous voulez
en fait à chaque fois qu on a une
information est un témoignage y compris
les radiesthésistes les voyants etc
c'est exploiter il ya des foules qui
sont réalisés et qui s'est jusqu'ici se
sont toujours révélées négatives
donc si la question est est ce qu'on l'a
retrouvé madame la juge heather la
réponse est non
fantasme de la mer s'il était là et qui
modulait
des échanges tout à l'heure par les
éléments sur sa personnalité vous ai
décrit comme impulsif
là
certains experts comportementaux qui ont
assisté aux auditions
c'est quasi impossible c'est juste je
pense que c'est plutôt des profiteurs
qui ont été utilisés dans le monde et
l'europe moi je porterais pas
d'appréciation c'est pour ça que tout à
l'heure j'ai évoqué l'importance des
éléments de personnalité qui vont être
réunis au delà de tout ce qui a été
constaté de témoignages étaient fermés
sous la responsabilité de l'instruction
notamment au niveau des expertises qui
ont évité et d'un certain nombre de
vérifications auprès d'amis de la
famille etc
moi je joue je vous disais tout à
l'heure constructivement ces séparations
et des eaux étaient potables d'éthique
du fils témoin je ne vais pas je vais
pas effectivement portent une
appréciation des experts pour ça je
pense que de nouvelles études à temps
une juge d'instruction qui risquent de
l'es10 j'étais très rapidement où l idée
alors pour les teams détenus je pense
que c'est assez
j'ai trois pouvaient des parties non ça
m'étonnerait pas ce qu'il appelle est
passée par là moi je voulais qu'il ya
mon unique apparition pour moi
l'interdît pas donc
le gd en toute indépendance et
impartialité rendu sa décision
donc moins plonger quand il a été
confirmé le mandat des pokémon est ici
bien sûr envie devant vous je pense mais
je ne peux pas vous le confirme serait
interrogé j'ai juste eu confirmation du
placement en détention
sauf milliards en forme et je n'ai pas
de précisions l'établissement local
sensex peut être je pense pas comme une
maison dans la nuit je pense que ça
serait pas raisonnable mais je vous le
confirme et si vous ne souhaitez ne
vendent pas d'antécédents les faux sont
en cours
comme les appelle
de sakhir
qui
un numéro d'appel un numéro vert est mis
en place
au début elle a été ensuite clôturées
nous parce que quand on reçoit toujours
des appels sur de nous donner si vous
souhaitez de recensement
sur sa journée
on sait ce qu'est la paix c'est par ses
abonnés
elle était prête à le tromper je crois
oui et il rentre et voilà le travail là
qu'ils y travaillent
elle rentre d'ailleurs à l'heure
actuelle c'est pour cela que dans les
conditions habituelles
comme je vous les décrivez sur le
véhicule sur ce cas-là pied on sait que
l'heure actuelle il manque les éléments
ex paradis
je pratique ou de recherche n'auraient
pas été tués ils vont être lancés tels
que le souhaitera son enquête
tu voudrais être encore ce sont les
juges d instruction et moi je n'ai fait
aucune autre
j'ai ouvert une information
immédiatement mais je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faites et je voulais dit et redit
les investigations vont se poursuivre il
ya de multiples actes qui restent à
diligenter y compris à ce niveau puisque
je le disais c'est le sait la
préoccupation centrale des enquêteurs au
delà des développements de l'enquêté
elle même donc oui je rejoins si ce que
dit monsieur en fonction des
désinformations tout est vérifié les
shaks chacun formation dopée viennent
chaque complément chacun suspicion
contour est à voir et immédiatement
exploité et reprises vous donnez une
note ce matin un spirit qui a appelé le
parquet au moment du déferrement
expliquant que huit années où étaient
même du bnetd mais il n'est pas donc
c'est pour vous dire que c'est ce que
disait le colonel et donc toutes les
pistes sont peut-être
on n'est pas sur des hypothèses
l'hypothèse était comme je vous le
disais dans la négative ce qui est acté
beaucoup plus au centre des
préoccupations c'est effectivement non
seulement la recherche des éléments
objectifs qui peuvent devenir des
charges après mais surtout d'objectiver
effectivement je me répète un certain
nombre d'éléments y compris sur tout ce
qui peut être possible oubliable voilà
vous venez de suivre en direct cette
très longue conférence de presse du
procureur de la république de toulouse
dominique alzeari qui s'est exprimé en
direct de toulouse sur l' enquête
concernant la disparition de delphine
jubilaire avec un très gros
rebondissement aujourd'hui puisque son
mari cédric joubert a été mise en examen
pour meurtre aggravé
alors cette conférence de presse était
volontairement long puisque comme on
l'avait expliqué juste avant la
communication avait été volontairement
retardé et le procureur avait
scrupuleusement ainsi que tous les
autres membres de l' enquête avait
scrupuleusement respecté le secret de
l'instruction
néanmoins il a délivré pas mal
d'informations notamment que 2500 acté
pv ont été réalisés dans le cas de ces
investigations ainsi qu'une quarantaine
d' expertise et de nombreuses opérations
de ratissage pour essayer de retrouver
donc delphine jus billard il a également
donné pas mal d'indicés sur cette nuit
sur la nuit de cette disparition
qu'est ce qu'on a appris est ce que vous
nous résumer les poils les points
principaux de cette conférence de presse
margot oui alors ce qui est ce qui est
ressorti effectivement brune c'est c'est
tout ce qui était les agissements
finalement de cédric du billard on a
entendu le procureur tout à l'heure qui
disait que lorsque les gendarmes
arrivent au domicile des jus milliards
il retrouve cédric en pyjama en train de
faire une machine à laver une machine
avec sa couette à 4 heures du matin 4 h
50 exactement bon ça pose quand même
question parce qu'il vient de
perdre nos fins de perdre sa femme est
portée disparue et la première chose
qu'il fait c'est une machine
c'est vrai que ça les a interpellés la
seconde chose qui a aussi interpellé les
enquêteurs c'est le fait que la voiture
du couple n'étaient pas garer dans le
même sens qu'elle qu'elle l'était
d'habitude delphine avait ses habitudes
gare est toujours la voiture la même
façon et là les voisins ont dit aux
enquêteurs qu'ils avaient trouvé ça
étrange qu'elle soit garée dans l'autre
sens et puis aussi bien sûr une les
enquêteurs n'ont pas trouvé de sang ça
aussi c'est un détail important et enfin
ils ont recueilli le témoignage du fils
du couple qui a dit qu alors qu'il était
couché il a entendu une violente dispute
comme d'ailleurs les voisins une dame et
sa fille qui ont entendu des cris
stridents d'une femme qui avait
longuement crié jusqu'à ce que ses cris
s'arrête et que les chiens se met à
aboyer
alors vous êtes très très nombreux dans
le chat vous nous avez suivi vous avez
suivi avec nous en direct cette
conférence du procureur beaucoup sont
arrivés en cours de route je vous salue
un nadia ou william alésia verse un seul
x officiel sub zero outsiders aux deux
side et karima dahmane qui nous saluent
qui nous dit bonne fin d'après-midi à
vous quelle affaire quel suspense
effectivement c'est une affaire avec
beaucoup de rebondissements et le
procureur a d'ailleurs donné quelques
détails sur la personnalité donc de
cédric julliard qui est désormais le
suspect numéro un dans cette affaire il
a été décrit donc je cite
je cite le procureur de la république
comme quelqu'un de brutales grossier et
agressif même envers ses enfants
est ce qu'on en sait un peu plus sur la
personnalité de cédric du billard alors
oui alors on a entendu le procureur qui
a expliqué que le couple rencontré deux
de grandes difficultés qu'il y avait
deux de graves difficultés conjugales
il a notamment indiqué que cédric
julliard ni est complètement qu'il y ait
eu un conflit entre lui et sa femme
au contraire lui disait que les
relations étaient très apaisé qu'il n'y
avait pas de souci particulier
alors que delphine jeux billard elle se
serait confié à ses proches et aurait
dit qu'elle avait voilà des problèmes
avec son mari que d'ailleurs elle avait
rencontré quelqu'un le fameux confident
de montauban et qu'elle qu'elle pensait
des ménages et refaire sa vie avec lui
elle avait même on a entendu monsieur
procureur le dire elle avait présenté
par visio apparemment ce je cite ce
monsieur comme comme le dit procureur
hase une fille voilà donc son fils avait
connaissance du fait que sa mère avait
rencontré quelqu'un on voyait quand il
lie le procureur a également dit qu'ils
étaient en train vraiment de se séparer
en procédure de divorce
donc voilà il y allait y allait avoir un
gros changement je pense dans cet
équilibre là et peut-être que cédric
julliard n'avais pas envie que tout cela
change aussi bien au niveau affectif que
financier merci margot loser if you're
dead dans le chat de notre page youtube
nous demande du coup cédric julliard a
été mise en examen pour homicide
effectivement donc pour meurtre aggravé
sur sur conjointe il me semble c'est la
dénomination exacte
c'est d'ailleurs le direct donc touche
maintenant à sa fin après donc plus
d'une heure 45 de direct je vais
remercier mon invité margot da des
marquis qui s'est entretenu avec nous
avec vous qui a répondu à vos questions
elle est journaliste au figaro
spécialiste fait divers réel et en
charge de la sphère julliard pour le
figaro vous pourrez donc retrouver tous
ses papiers tous ces articles sur
lefigaro.fr dès à présent en vous
connectant
sur la homepage du figaro quant à moi je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup d'avoir été aussi
nombreux donc sur lefigaro.fr et sur
youtube je vais saluer donc marie maffre
qui nous a vraiment suivi depuis le
début clovis marc bideau mac
catherine dit mercure yushan six
officiels et google m'espionne ainsi que
christine dijon vous êtes beaucoup
beaucoup je ne peux pas tout vous saluer
en tout cas à très vite pour un prochain
direct et je remercie réate bekir à la
réalisation
à bientôt sur figaro live